welcome back to Pierce Morgan uncensored
it's a simple question that now
terrifies politicians the world over and
it's this what is a woman well
conservative podcast host Matt Walsh in
a moment of defined intervention has
made a documentary about it and it's
called simply what is a woman and it's
out now
what is a woman can you tell me that
[Music]
oh you're at the women's March you must
have some idea please if one person
could tell me what a woman is
for women we ask you to leave what is
that a woman is not anything in
particular there is not one particular
thing it could be many things to many
people some women have penises right
some men have vaginas I like scented
candles and I've watched Sex in the City
yeah how do I know if I'm a woman that's
a great question you're not a scientist
you're not a gender Studies major no how
do you know that you're a man I guess
because I got a dick can a man become a
woman
I'm not a woman so I I can't really
answer that women only know what women
are are you a cat no can you tell me
what a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is
well that was joins me now Matt great to
talk to you it's a it's a fascinating
documentary because the chronic
inability of apparently sane intelligent
individuals to answer this incredibly
simple question is breathtaking and you
know we're seeing it all over the world
now as senior politicians everywhere and
we saw it with katanji brown Jackson
this is a woman who's now a Supreme
Court Justice this is what she said when
she was asked about this in her
confirmation hearing
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can I provide a definition no yeah
I
can't
you can't
not in this context I'm not a biology
I'll be Matt what do you when you heard
that when you heard a Supreme Court
Justice nominees saying I can't say what
a woman is even though she is one
because she's not a biologist what did
you think
well first I thought this was great
timing because we were going to announce
our film that week and then that moment
happened it was just it was kind of
Divine Providence I think as you put it
out
um you know there's there's two
different things going on here you've
got people who can't answer the question
who are actually confused about it and
that's quite terrifying that people are
confused about something as simple as
this but then you also have people who
are pretending to be confused when
they're not really which is actually
even more concerning in a lot of ways
and I think that cantanji brown Jackson
I'm going to assume given that she's a
very successful intelligent person
um that uh and she is a woman herself
and realizes that she's a woman I think
she's in the latter category where she
actually knows that a woman is a female
but is pretending that she doesn't know
because she's beholden to this ideology
that has you know basically backs her
into this corner and so she has to feign
ignorance about something as simple as
this right I mean I asked uh the
president of the in the UK the national
Union students president a young woman a
very bright young woman but I Master
what is a woman out of interest and she
thought I was trying to trap her she
actually thought I was I would this was
a trap I said no I'm just asking you
what you think a woman is it's not a
trap it shouldn't be a trap how have we
got here Matt how have we got to a place
where young women are paralyzed with
fear about even saying what they are
this is a gender of ideology I mean
that's what that's what this is and uh
uh you know you could kind of if you
want to trace it back you could kind of
decide how far back you want to go there
are certain Landmark moments you can
point to in history and I think for a
lot of people it feels like everyone
knew what a woman was and a man was a
man a woman was a woman up until about
eight years ago and then everyone lost
their minds uh but it actually traces
back farther that in the film we go back
and we trace it back to guys like John
money and Alfred Kinsey you know
sexologists and uh and psychoanalysts in
the mid 20th century who came up with
what we know today as sort of the the
early iteration of modern day gender
ideology and I think they got it into
the institutions especially higher you
know Academia those kinds of
Institutions and then from there it sort
of filtered down to General Public maybe
about eight years ago is when it sort of
exploded onto the mainstream scene and
uh took over at least Western the
Western world after that point I think
and where is gut I think really
dangerous and Insidious actually to
society is particularly in issues like
sport where you see trans athletes now
dominating in women's sport we had an
example of this at the weekend where a a
biological male skateboarder who was uh
32 I think or something
um this person decided to compete uh as
a woman as now transitioned to be a
woman in the skateboarding competition
in New York against girls as young as 12
and destroyed the field and won this is
what that the trans athletes said
afterwards
I find that funny because that's like
what I'm getting beat up about the most
is like you're beating little kids and
little girls and I'm just like uh I
didn't intend to do that like I just
this was the first competition that I've
been to that I actually wanted to win
the skill levels again really determined
by your just like your
your determination your tenacity to just
like
put yourself in on top and through these
obstacles it has nothing to do with your
age do you think you have a physical
Advantage I'm like look at me I'm not
like buff or anything you know I don't
think skateboarding has anything to do
with physicality
I mean I actually Ricky Tres there is 29
or 32 but the the competition that was a
girl who came second was 12. the kind of
level of delusion there that there was
no physical Advantage from being a
biological male that's where we've got
to they genuinely believe there's
nothing wrong with this but it's clearly
to me transparently unfair
right well we also live in a world where
now you can't say pregnant woman you say
pregnant people because supposedly men
get pregnant this is this is the
ultimate this is the Emperor has no
clothes and and almost everybody you
look at that and you and if you're asked
does it make sense to have a 29 year old
father of three competing in the women's
competition against 13 year old girls if
people feel like they're in a position
where they could be honest about it
almost everyone is going to say
obviously no by the way about that
particular individual he actually did an
interview about a year ago where he said
that he knows he's not a woman but he
but he wants to be cute and feminine
like women and so that's what he's
trying to do he actually says that so
it's got to the point now where someone
you know they don't even affirm
themselves as a woman and yet we have to
do that it just doesn't it doesn't make
any sense at all how is your documentary
gone down matt have you have you had a
lot of pressure not to give it much air
time
yeah well it's been interesting so it's
you know we've fortunately been able to
get outside of kind of the conservative
podcast bubble and reach a mainstream
audience which is what we wanted to do
and the reception and that kind of
General audience has been really
overwhelmingly good and people are happy
this film is out there the mainstream
critics though have just decided they're
going to ignore this movie completely
you go to Rotten Tomatoes right now and
you'll find that not one single
mainstream film critic has reviewed the
film we sent the screeners to mainstream
critics and they told us uh I I don't I
refuse to watch I'm not going to watch
anything from the daily wire and and uh
so they won't even look at it they
refuse to even take the time to see what
we can present which is complete Madness
because I've watched it with great
Fascination it's very well made it's a
very simple premise and the results
frankly are startling and pretty
disconcerting uh final question Matt in
the interest of fair play what is a man
well if a woman is an adult human female
then I suppose a man would be an adult
human male I would say I think it really
is as simple as that Matt Walsh thank
you very much for joining me I
appreciate it
thank you appreciate it